the Apple watch officially goes on sale
today but there's some confusion on how
customers can get their hands on it
won't be available in the stores you
can't walk in and buy it it's only
accepting them on online orders at this
point and if you preorder then you're
likely to get it today since the
SmartWatch was announced in September
shares of Apple as you can see up over
thirty percent Bloomberg pursuits
stephen pohl brent was lucky enough to
get a hold of one of these watches hold
it up season I've got one right here
I've had it a total of about 12 hours
still still getting it all set up
getting used to it but they do go on
sale today okay people are going to
start getting them delivered it seems
like they're gonna get them earlier than
expected people who weren't expecting
them until May June are getting their
shipment emails so maybe apples don't
bring ahead of schedule here well what
do you think so far I mean it's nice by
the way which one you have I have the
basic Apple watch okay standard learns
by Apple this was loaned by Apple I have
this for a little while to kind of get a
feel for it and see see what I think and
how it fits into my life okay so what do
you think so far so good I mean unlike
any other Apple product it takes some
getting used to you pull your iPhone out
of the box and you know what to expect
you know what your iphone does this is
different you have to get it set up you
have to figure out which notifications
you want apps were allowed today like
you said we have over 3000 apps are
gonna roll out today only 500 apps
rolled out for the iphone on day one so
it's going to be a lot and they're still
rolling out Facebook isn't available yet
we'll hopefully see that later today
okay we might see something from google
I don't know we'll see as it rolls out
well tell us some of the some of the
apps that are some of the companies that
have developed apps for this watch we
who are they I mean so actually we have
an app for Bloomberg business which lets
you track your watch list and let you
see the brief okay you can kind of
scroll through here and you can't read
full stories but you can flag them and
read them later online you can go
through them you can check your your
watch list and are you having is it easy
to read it's pretty easy to read
displays are much more limited than on
the phone and functionalities much more
limited than on the phone so uber for
example doesn't show you a map it just
shows you how long you're going to wait
for a car and you can either request it
or not request it anything you want to
change you have to pull your
phone out to do that okay actually here
we go okay I wanted one of the guys to
pull these up so these are all the
different companies that have better put
apps on here right so American Airlines
right maybe you can book your ticket on
your watch I don't know expedia maybe I
knew it looks like you can buy buy
things on Amazon from your watch by
things on amazon so targets on your
TripAdvisor twitter you can sweet from
your watch so I mean yes there's what
much more here open table so you know
basically as we say three thousand plus
i mean i can grab three thousand plus
apps on your watch I don't think so but
okay so overall your impression is that
it is that it's pretty useful than here
it's pretty useful the hardware is nice
I think the big question is how will the
apps function how are they going to
change over time I think it's it's the
first device where we really have to
wait and see we don't know yet I mean
how how I use the watch face whether I
prefer to use Twitter in a more
simplified way or a more robust way I
think they're gonna get a lot of
feedback and apps are going to be
changing very frequently on this once
they roll out and how many are they
expected to ship in total me what are we
talking about we've heard estimates so
far of anywhere from 1 million to 10
million I think it's somewhere in the
two to three range so far and
projections are saying it could be
double digits by the end of the year
double digits of these watches will all
be wearing them maybe and walking around
knocking into people even more probably